[Music]
do you
like mcdonald's ice cream stuff like ice
cream products like mcflurry
i like the mcflurry or the cone oh i
haven't had a mcdonald's ice cream in so
long
i do and i i know that their soft serve
is you know
it's quite popular it's unrivaled it's
unrivaled it is i agree
even to the point where people know
where the good soft servant you know
locations are
you know what my friend made me try to
do he
he had french fries and a [ __ ] soft
serve and then he got me one and he's
like all right it's the best and then
you dip it
yeah you never tried that i tried it
with them but it was so [ __ ] weird
i didn't do it again i can't do it i
don't i just like i
eat it and then i'll eat it i don't
understand that no
it's sweet and savory like it's that you
don't eat sweet and savory stuff
together like
what i don't know man french fries a
french fry
wait isn't ketchup kind of like sort of
a little bit of sweet tangy yeah yeah do
you drink soda when you eat fries
she's got you there wow boom buy the
balls
take your shirt off that's like you're
playing strip facts did you
did you did you put it no no no leave it
on
did you blend it his word there we go he
wanted to take it off anyway
he just gave him a reason even if you
got it wrong i know it's
it's it's a hot dog taika has a picture
just like that one more and you're fully
nude because it's just two pieces of
clothing
i am wearing underwear today thank god
well what's another thing that they're
famous for with their ice cream
the fact that it's always broken it's
always broken
they take the cone from the ice cream
instead of the cone oh i gave her the
answer
yeah the fact that it's not how to get
it out oh okay i don't even know
no they say they're cleaning the machine
all right you do you know that people
were doing the stupid [ __ ] they would go
order an ice cream right and then the
the teller i mean the cashier will give
it out like this
and then they would grab it from the top
of the ice cream oh my god
oh i i
oh my god people are so dumb so they pay
for it just for it to drop
because they want to go viral wow i mean
it's only a dollar
i'll do anything for abuse we have
we have done everything yeah we need the
views
i can't judge i did some stupid [ __ ]
what's the number one thing that
pops in your head that you are like i
kissed a transgender woman
that i was attracted to oh and what's
wrong with that nothing's wrong with it
oh but it wasn't i wouldn't have done it
if it wasn't for videos
for videos yeah yeah but then i got to
like it
that's good and i did it i brought it
invited her back to do it again that's
tight
who was it again i remember her name was
kimber james that's right kimber james
and she was um pre-op
oh okay for the first kiss for the
wiener for the both kisses
okay and but she had a big big set of
boobs
just great body you know and uh we
kissed and then i get an email i think
you know
maybe a year later saying she had
completed the you know and if she wanted
oh wow
if i needed her for anything else to let
her know so she was like
for videos you know oh i was like dang
you gave her a good
business two business emails for
business
um look needed me for anything else ever
i have a sexuality and i've said this
before it's like on a it's a spectrum
right so
absolutely you know i'm not i'm not the
straightest
you just said in another video that was
in the last video this is a different
video
fresh start that makes sense i'm i'm
okay so if here's
completely gay here's straight i'm like
hang on why did you start on that side
wait oh just i'll do this
i'll be the spectrum because we don't
know where it ends well it's over here
okay it's too far i'm so out of frame
i'm somewhere over here
it keeps moving i do it i do a lot of i
do a lot of fun stuff but it was mainly
for comedy and steve you know for comedy
everything sexuality is all it's all
yeah bart's kids several guys have you
under the guise of comedy
i know the guys i'll do anything for
comedy yeah
i'll do anything anything for the joke
that means bart would honestly make her
out with you right now
you would well barbara was funny yeah if
he was it was part of a certain yeah not
me
i'm not a real comedian that's for
science mm-hmm
wow would you look great with your shirt
off would you let him kiss you
uh i mean i would but like because of
covid it's because of cove yeah
otherwise i would totally be on on him
that's really sensible
uh listen [ __ ] i'm right here you're
not gonna be
i would be on him under guys
of comedy under the guise of comedy and
we like to do three rehearsals before
the real take-house
with tongues yes because they're
professionals yeah we gotta know they're
method actors
yeah all right back to mcdonald's ice
cream here of course
so this 24 year old software engineer
launched this website called mcbroken
which will it has this map of all the
mcdonald's around
the united states and i believe around
the world too how many
are there well how come there's so many
[ __ ] up ones on the east coast
well because there's more of them wait
do they work or okay so green means that
they're working
and red means that they're not so damn
dude from the mississippi river and on
we don't got that many mcdonald's
yeah so then here's l.a wow we have a
shittiest
[ __ ] ton this is all kind of [ __ ]
though because i heard that
the employees clean it at a certain time
and then they don't want to have to
leave it overnight and have to clean it
again in the morning so that's why they
cut it off at a certain point
that's what i have heard anyway but
sometimes they really do
just break and they're they just sit
there all broken and
i can attest to this because we have a
soft surf machine and we know people
that surf soft serve
as well and those [ __ ] break
all the time
they need to make a better machine yeah
the better ones cost as much as a car
though
so that's why and you're very yeah but
when you're starting off you don't got
that kind of money you start off with
bootstrap money okay
why come mcdonald's has the best soft
serve though like them yeah
because it's not even milk yo but have
you had am pm though
am pm soft serve is [ __ ] good gas
stations
chevrons oh you gotta look for one
because i don't think they have any many
people not know what ampm is dude
i'm not trash dude wow good for you
but yeah well you don't know how to live
then because trash food is the [ __ ]
best
well yeah so rashik the engineer who
created this website is an indian guy
yeah from berlin needing guys are taking
all our jobs
and i've said it before thank you nobody
says it
no one's saying they're not taking my
job because i have no competition
uh please keep doing what you're doing a
nice indian tech
smart tech guys yeah we asked what he
did start the new instagram
he reverse engineered um
some software program stuff where if you
were able to
order an ice cream product through the
mcdonald's app
then that's how you know that the
machine is working and if you can't then
that means the machine is not working
and so he was able to get gather that
information from the mcdonald's app
and then make it into a website where
every 30 minutes so initially
it was every minute that he was ordering
like an ice cream cone or whatever it
was and it totaled up to like
18 000 something like that um but
then eventually the app ended up finding
out that
he had a bot it was a bot not a human so
then how would they check
i guess the app just it's the it needed
to do the
like the traffic lights it had to ping
it yeah
if you know about servers all this kind
of [ __ ] then you know that kind of [ __ ]
yeah so
it knew that it was the same like ip or
whatever it is
ordering every single minute the same
item
and so it just kicked him out so anyway
the point is that he had a lot of trial
and error and then he concluded that it
the sweet spot is 30 minutes so every 30
minutes he's ordering an ice cream
product from all of the locations
and canceling ordering and cancelling i
don't know if he's canceled a lot of
money because it seems as though like he
is so he's ordering making i don't know
[ __ ] doors
he's getting that ice cream postmates or
whatever the [ __ ] maybe he's cancelling
i don't know they didn't include 20 000
ice creams every day
every 30 minutes all over the world i
think the point is
a lot of money i think the point is to
just like make sure if he's able to even
order it so maybe if
maybe he doesn't have to go through the
thing oh maybe it stops right before
checkout yeah probably
it's like we have it available oh right
now out of order
is this guy okay well he loves his
mcdonald's ice cream okay like
i think that is um like wow he's
thinking for the rest of us
honestly yeah because in the past there
have been like there was an
attempt to try to do something along the
lines of this
where you can find out if the ice cream
machine is working or not but in the
past
it was like user submitted so you had to
talk about that submit yourself to see
like
yeah it's working right now but this one
it's like automatically
you can go if you're craving some
mcdonald's ice cream right now go on
that website and see
if your local mcdonald's has their
machine working and it's
it's a really good website you know what
they need to do
you know how like uh krispy kreme has
their light on when there's fresh donuts
they need a light on for the fresh fries
because i don't want to go in there and
get these [ __ ]
up fries bart has some insider tips the
oil what do you do i had a buddy in high
school that told me
so he was a assistant manager at uh
mcdonald's
high school you had the hick you got the
hook i don't know how you got promoted
but
the assistant manager yeah what happened
was it your ocean yeah
all right you know wow okay dude he's
got the inside scoop
let me sit up okay and uh he was saying
that
he's name-dropping in front of us right
like [ __ ] flexing right now
yeah he was uh he was funny because
after our first guest who's talking
about joe rogan and stuff
and name dropping joe rogan and cool all
these cool communities and stuff yeah
like
bart's like my friend's assistant
manager mcdonald's in high school
he wasn't even impressed the whole time
oh that's what we should do with these
[ __ ] hollywood parties man like yeah
i got a friend
assistant manager at mcdonald's oh and
corporate nah like one of the locations
in eastern
real deal the real deal yeah and uh so
they would change their what is it
called
oil they're frying oil once a week on
like i think on mondays
and then so he he was saying that if not
tuesday so if you want to get the best
tasting fries you got to come on monday
because then the oil is seven days old
and that's when it's like really
seasoned with all the wonders sometimes
the fries
taste a little too quick like too clean
right some countries in the street
you know the street food they'd never
change their oil yeah i heard that too
no never yeah i watched some videos
heating it up it's been going on for 70
years or something yeah
i'm sure anthony bourdain or andrew
zimmern ate
you know it's just it's like completely
orange
or you know black and it's just
constantly being looking
i watched this one show where it was
like a soup broth or something that's
like 200 years old
yeah they constantly put new broth in
and take it out but they never it never
gets the point like the mother dough
when you make sourdough yeah
and they never last for years and years
and years and they never cleaned around
the sides is
because it had a bunch of [ __ ] caked on
the sides of it you know what i'm
talking about
oh that's the thai noodle soup one yeah
that one's like 100 years old
i do the same thing with my coffee cup i
never wash my coffee cup i just put
nothing goes in it but coffee so it's
like seven years old it's just brown on
the inside
seasoned but i get that extra you know
a little bit of this residue yeah
bacteria am i gross no
yeah yeah i'll rinse it he's single
ladies
that's right slide in
you